this right over here is a scratch pad on
khan academy created by khan academy
user charlotte allen
and what you see here is a simulation
that allows us to keep sampling from our
gumball machine and start approximating
the sampling distribution of the sample
proportion
so her simulation focuses on green
gumballs but we talked about yellow
before in the yellow gumballs we said 60
were yellow so let's make 60 percent
here green
and then let's take samples of 10 just
like we did before
and then let's just start with one
sample so we're going to draw one sample
and what we want to show is we want to
show the percentages which is the
proportion of each sample that are green
so if we draw that first sample notice
out of the 10 5 ended up being green and
then it plotted that right over here
under 50 percent we have one situation
where 50 were green now let's do another
sample so this sample 60 are green and
so let's keep going
let's draw another sample and now that
one we have
we have 50 are green and so notice now
we see here on this distribution two of
them were had 50 green and we could keep
drawing samples
and let's just really increase so we're
going to do 50 samples of 10 at a time
and so here we can quickly get to a
fairly large number of samples so here
we're over a thousand samples and what's
interesting here is we're seeing
experimentally that our sample the the
mean of our sample proportion here is
0.62 what we calculated a few minutes
ago was that it should be 0.6 we also
see that the standard deviation of our
sample proportion is 0.16 and what we
calculated was approximately 0.15
and as we draw more and more samples we
should get even closer and closer to
those
values and we see that for the most part
we are getting closer and closer in fact
now that it's rounded we're at exactly
those values that we had calculated
before
now one interesting thing to observe is
when your population proportion is not
too close to zero and not too close to
one this looks pretty close to a normal
distribution and that makes sense
because we saw the relation between the
sampling distribution of the sample
proportion and a binomial random
variable but what if our population
proportion is closer to zero so let's
say our population proportion is
0.1 what do you think the distribution
is going to look like then
well we know that the mean
of our sampling distribution is going to
be 10
and so you can imagine that the
distribution is going to be right skewed
but let's actually see that
so
here we see that our distribution is
indeed
right skewed and that makes sense
because you can only get values from 0
to 1 and if your mean is closer to zero
then you're going to see the meat of
your distribution here and then you're
going to see a long tail to the right
which creates that right skew
and if your population proportion was
close to one well you can imagine the
opposite's going to happen you're going
to end up with a left skew
and we indeed see right over here a
left skew
now the other interesting thing to
appreciate is the larger your samples
the smaller the standard deviation and
so let's
let's do a population proportion that is
right in between
and so here
this is similar to what we saw before
this is looking roughly normal
but now and that's when we had sample
size of 10
but what if we have a sample size of 50
every time
well notice now it looks like a much
tighter
distribution
this isn't even going all the way to one
yet but it is a much tighter
distribution and the reason why that
made sense
the standard deviation of your sample
proportion it is inversely proportional
to the square
root of n and so that makes sense so
hopefully you have a good intuition now
for the sample proportion its
distribution the sampling distribution
of the sample proportion that you can
calculate its mean and its standard
deviation and you feel good about it
because we saw it in a simulation